what should I name my business so I got
a great question from one of my
newsletter readers Taiyo thank you for
writing in had a great question love you
guys
the question was I have in business plan
check although I found out that there's
a company with a similar name in the
States so back to the drawing board
about name sweat business I checked you
don't seem to have any zookas on names
from your business or do you if not
would you be able to give me any tips
Thank You taya it's a great question I
think everybody struggles with other
than starting their business what do i
name my company and I don't have a zoo
good on this because I don't think it's
that important I mean I think people put
too much importance on it instead of
focusing on what's really important
creating something of value bring
something people are really going to
care about so here are some examples
okay I used to have this infographic
that I that I talked about different
companies and how they came up with
their names and I don't know where it
was so I can't show it with you but I
love Milan success I love looking at how
famous entrepreneurs build their
companies and if you look to see where
they came up with their names for their
businesses it's all over the map okay
you have there's a lot of business
business experts will say hey your
company's got to say exactly what you do
right it should say whatever you know
Jill's accounting service it should
state exactly what your company does but
that's that's BS you know you look at
successful companies you look at the
biggest companies in the world a lot of
them don't say how they they don't say
what they do right you look at their
companies you wouldn't have an idea what
they do do so you know what example that
is IBM right IBM was an International
Business Machines so Thomas says what
they do but they've appreciated it some
people name their companies after
themselves you look at Ferrari
Lamborghini Armani right it's their own
last name some companies like to take a
word in a different language that has
meaning to them and they put that in
there so you know Nike is the Greek
goddess of victory
how many people know that who knows but
it has a deeper meaning for them some
companies just like having a name that
is complicated to do it on purpose
a guy who created Xerox created a hard
name on purpose
like magic name starts with real no
Xerox Knapp right but the name started
with sex with an X right X er o X Xerox
if you saw it for the first time you
probably wouldn't say Xerox we at X or X
or ox right the reason why he did that
was he felt like as soon as somebody
remembered they would never forget so it
was how he stood out with his name
virgin Richard Branson's company they
started it because when kind of cope
with a company name they were all young
and they had never been in business so
they're all virgins in business so they
called the company virgin Sony is a
combination of sonís which is Latin for
sound and Sunny Boy which was a popular
expression in in in America at the time
that Sony came over that's how Sony came
about our PO is Oprah Winfrey's company
Harpo is Oprah backwards so there's tons
of different ways to do it there's no
there's no one right way you know
ideally you pick something that has some
meaning to you that has some kind of
story behind it but at the end of the
day the customer it's not going to care
that much what the company name is all
about don't stress out so much about the
company name and instead focus on
creating something that has deep value
and meaning for people write your
product or service that's what you want
to focus on and not so much with the
company name that's my two cents I love
to hear what you have to think let me
know below in the comments how you came
up with your company name let me know
what you think about finding a company
name leave it in the comments I'd love
to read it
you guys like this video thumbs up below
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
see